oh [__]
get your uncle Joey he's back in black
it's Monday you guys are saying where
the [__] you been Joe I've been busy
you understand me it's tough to smoke
reefer in a [__] mall in Nyack New
York so I got to walk around like like a
black dude in 1940 trying to smoke a
reefer but it's a beautiful day to be
alive
the birds are out the sun's the chirping
you got a big dick and you're ready for
the day oh [__]
we got some super glue from perennial
and we got some [__] Saturday I'm
sayin you want to go to Saturn it's time
to hang out with uncle Joey on a Monday
morning
hey I've this thing in dick I've been
given our bubblegum [__] New York
fantastic fantastic I had a great time
if you came to one of the shows nobody
nobody is better than you except for
that [__] Momo on Saturday night that
would you shut the [__] up like he did a
team [__] blast of coast but that's
the past the future is in your hands
[__] you know why cuz it's Monday
do your push-ups write your goals pull
out your dick and tell them how you're
giving out milk and a taint skin you
know I'm sayin
anyway let's load up
on the first bowl of the [__] day if
I said that the ABS line I was out here
like 6:15 [__] blasted off to nowhere
but then the helicopters there watching
uncle Joey but they can't stop us
I feel like [__] Henry Hill and
Goodfellas at the end but [__] it here
we are
look we're you're ready to [__] go
uncle Joey got your back
we got a podcast tonight eight o'clock
it's gonna [__] rock the house leaves
and training beside that I feel good I
look good I got my hand up Monalisa
skirt and nobody [__] knows it you
understand me we're banging our finger
bangers in the [__]
every way you got you know why cuz you
remember the church at that time to
dilly-dally what's going on today oh my
god I think I'm gonna get my passport
and go to Nick get the [__] out here you
can't deal with it here what the [__]
you're gonna run away listen spark the
bowl write your goals down write down
exactly what you want give it six months
and you're right [__] there how do I
know I lived it [__] enough with
the chitty-chat we got a spark up a
little bit
just like that tip-top Magoo [__]
uncle Joey's here ready to go on a
Monday my night Joey I needed you on
Friday
hey go out me uh smoke yourself at
yourself on the head with a stick and
uncle Joey you're a pig you know I'm
sounding like I Dream of Jeannie when
you least expect me I show up with a big
dick and an umbrella
that's how we do it and I suggest you do
the same it's Monday baby boy whatever
happened last week happened last week
whatever happened last year your
girlfriend dumped you I'm not feeling
good I'm going through a depression
listen I wiped my [__] with
depression you gotta get up look at the
man in the mirror and go this is what
I'm doing today whether they like it and
that I don't give a [__] while they're
all goofing around worried about oh my
god they bomb a bug who gives a [__] I'm
finger-banging Mona Lisa cuz nobody's
watching everybody's focusing on the
stupidity things that they got on the
news don't watch the news no more you're
not allowed to watch the news the other
thing you're allowed to watch his
periscope and uncle Joey I give you the
real news you know what the news is
about today you and how you're gonna
conquer the world not the rest of these
people
two kids got hit by a car once I got to
do with me you want to bring me down at
8:00 in the morning I can't even enjoy
my [__] cornflakes yeah I'm saying
when I can face I want to be in a
positive mood on places as American
that's good [__] beer come on face an
apple you wash your [__] you go out
there like a [__] marine right out of
boot camp you follow me
but I don't need to tell you this you
knew this already why cuz you're a bad
[__] from across the street
you'll kick my ass from tree to tree you
follow me
so you got to look in the mirror and say
to yourself what do I really want out of
this [__] life I want to keep being a
mud hanging out with these [__] much
or do I is the world flat I don't give a
[__] if it's a triangle I'm still
walking on it like I'm a [__] king
you understand me how do you become a
king by taking that to the next [__]
lovely weather it would be pay whatever
the [__] it is by doing something
outside your comfort zone and [__]
grown it did I like going to jujitsu
smelling [__] and feet no but it
makes me a better [__] man it makes
me better on stage why cuz I commit to
when you commit to something mentally
they can't stop you little things little
commitments become big commitments you
understand me
let's mope another boat Joey what the
[__] you telling Confucius and heat shut
the [__] up I'm trying to get high I'm
trying to have a good [__] day I'm
just trying to help ya
hey you go look at that [__] clap
Jesus couldn't blow clown like that if
you had a magician in his [__] pocket
but that's a complete different story
understatement
today I'm not even feeling Jewish I'm
feeling like a [__] Hebrew I'm ready
to go I'm marketing that dog you know
which one the main one between your
[__] legs that's the [__] Hebrew
national I'm slinging today
[__] and I suggest you do the
same you understand me but then Joey I
saw another boat and should this is
empty I brought out the wrong canister
but this one ain't the debt of two legs
you understand me let's see what the
[__] we got here bye oh I see that's a
cow a loony then gonna ping up a la
sorry that means your dick is standing
up and ready to salute the [__]
think it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive the sun's starting to come out of
the clouds but even if the Sun didn't
come out I think I know they do with me
because I got juju juice in my nuts
that's ready to heat up the [__]
party if I need it
alright don't forget eight o'clock
tonight the Churchill what's happening
now and then April [__] 24 2011 II
live Oxnard stars a death Lisa at the
whole [__] caboodle make sure you're
there you want to see somebody old Dion
wheel until the ambulance don't get
there
it ain't a [__] party so anyway I see
you [__] tonight 8 o'clock be
there or be square
I got an audition I go to jujitsu a
little bit today and do drew I can't go
to class on this one I go drill I wanna
climb you know how we do it you gotta
commit to it every day every day get my
ass kicked but every day I get that much
[__] stronger and that's all that
matters and I suggest you do the same
you understand me
I'm coming out the Bakersfield the 27
and Salt Lake City get your [__]
together you're opening up the month of
May with uncle Joey then we're taking it
to [__] Wisconsin
at the Michigan one night fetus Joey
Diaz dotnet I'm coming to your town
we're gonna buy out the reefer guy
understand me [__] from the
bottom of my heart without you I got
[__] nothing
have a great day keep your eyes open
Isis is everywhere and remember the
biggest dick in the room is you when you
walked in there they all got a bow down
and suck your dick they don't know
nothing about what you have in your
[__] coconut you understand me drop
knowledge on them and that's enough is
enough I love you [__] from the
bottom of my heart I'll see you tonight
at eight o'clock right
hey get or you they get on my mom I love
you [__] see you later
the [__] is wrong with these people
bother